Speaker 1: Welcome back to the show. Luke Beasley
filling in for David while he is away. If you
want to check me out. You like what you see
Luke Beasley on YouTube. The link should be
in the description if you're watching on YouTube.
Radical Republican Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
GREENE appeared on Fox News with Sean HANNITY
and continuing in her tour of trying to make
herself more mainstream. Let's forget all the
past bonkers conspiracy theories, things I've
said and make me a serious congresswoman. And
conservative media is assisting in that. And
the Republican Party insisting that well.
Especially the third clip I'm going to show
you out of this interview really highlights
how little both Sean HANNITY and Marjorie
GREENE understand about what they're talking
about. And it's honestly really embarrassing
for these two individuals. But before we
do that, the first two clips relate to
the removing of certain Democratic congresspeople
from committee. So I'll show you these and
then we'll get to the really bonkers clip.
Speaker 2: No, not at all. And you can see
there's a major difference in the leadership with
Kevin McCarthy as speaker of the House and Nancy
Pelosi as Speaker of the House. Nancy Pelosi
and the Democrats removed me from committees
from things they didn't like on my Facebook
years before I became a member of Congress.
But you can see that Kevin McCarthy isn't being
political. He's removing members of Congress
that need to be removed. It's a.
Speaker 1: So she's correct that.
Nancy Pelosi and Kevin McCarthy are very different
in the type of speaker they're going to be, but
not in the way that she would believe necessarily.
And I'll show you the next clip, actually, and
then we'll discuss about this committee's issue.
Speaker 2: Kevin McCarthy is speaker of the House
is doing the right thing and removing
these Democrat members that deserve to
be removed. Ilhan Omar is another example.
She's anti-Semitic and she should not be
on foreign affairs. These aren't political
things. These are the right things to do.
Speaker 1: So. From the Jewish space lasers
believing person. She's saying that Ilhan Omar is
anti-Semitic and that's why she shouldn't
be on committees. Hmm. But to the point of
Kevin McCarthy is not doing these
actions for political purposes,
but instead for good reason is completely silly,
because I don't think there's any better reason
to remove someone from committees than the reason
Democrats did. Paul Gosar posting that animation
of AOC getting killed, and then Marjorie
GREENE and all four conspiracy theories,
the Jewish space lasers and all of that. Those
are good reason that someone probably shouldn't
be serving on committees. It's absolutely 100%
political that Kevin McCarthy is taking people
off of committees that are perfectly qualified
to serve in those positions but are Democrats.
And that's the real reason. Okay. So third clip,
watch them discuss and watch how Sean HANNITY sets
up the conversation around the debt ceiling and
how deeply confused he gets. And then Marjorie
GREENE just goes along with the confusion.
Speaker 3: Let me ask you, I know the Democrats
desperately want to distract from the the issue of
the president and classified top secret documents
now in four locations. I get that. So they're
trying to gin up the American people on the issue
of the debt ceiling. My understanding is that
really won't be an issue for a number of months.
But when it is an issue, what will Republicans do?
Will they be united? What are the things that they
will demand in exchange for going along with the
debt ceiling? Because of the hyperbole I'm sure
will be out of control. A full faith and credit
of the United States government is on the line and
credit of the government is on the line. Are you
going to shut down the government? And meanwhile,
people will still get their Social Security
checks and Medicare. The military will be up
and running and most people get a furlough and
then get paid when they get back to work. So
all that hyperbole is coming. But what will the
Republicans want and will they stay together?
Speaker 1: Okay, so we will let Marjorie GREENE
answer. But first, let's just kind of break down
what was so confused about that setup to the
question. What do you do there? He merged the
concepts of funding the government and raising the
debt ceiling. Now, these things will coincide and
the negotiations might get intertwined and
be going on at similar times. And but the
the funding of the government and the government
shutdowns that are threatened is different
than the raising of the debt ceiling and us
falling through on our financial obligations.
So he's correct that whenever we get in the
negotiations about funding the government,
if they don't come to an agreement within
the government and the government shuts down.
The necessary functions of the government still
move forward. But if it goes on long enough,
negative consequences absolutely occur. But then
he shifted and kind of blended into the full faith
and credit of the United States and the fact
that we would be in a bad economic situation
and we would be losing worldwide credibility if we
didn't raise the debt ceiling and follow through
on our financial obligations. And blending those
two things in is set up to make it seem like it's
not a big deal and they're going to fearmonger. So
whenever you hear it, don't take it seriously. But
we should take seriously both of those things. But
not raising the debt ceiling could be disastrous.
And it's not the time to argue over spending. If
you don't want the government to spend as much,
you have to push for that when you're deciding on
spending. That makes a whole lot of sense, which
would be when you're passing bills, when you're
debating over the funding of different programs.
But when you talk about raising the debt ceiling,
that's just following through on financial
obligations, spending that's already been
committed to. And we must do that to stay credible
as a government with that. And all of those
things. And so he's completely discombobulated
setting up that question. But here's your answer.
Speaker 2:
Well, I think this is an important issue to
talk about. Sean, thank you for bringing it
up. But we also want to point out that
Nancy Pelosi, Chuck Schumer, Joe Biden,
Mitch McConnell, all of whom have served, if
you add up the years they've been in Congress
or in power in Washington, we're looking
at 150 years of four people's combined
time in Washington. So they know what they're
doing when they kick the can down the road,
giving the debt ceiling issue to the Republican
majority, which we started here in January. It's
an important issue for our conference to come
together on because, as you said, the government
will keep on running. Yes, people social.
Speaker 1: And again, she's merging the
concepts. But we will skip forward to
a pretty notable part here at the end.
Speaker 2: Have to have. I, for one, will not
sign a clean bill raising the debt the debt limit.
Speaker 1: So she won't. Buy in to a
clean bill raising the debt ceiling.
There it is. And I've talked about extensively now
on my show that this is the Republican nonsense
we saw foreshadowed with the Kevin McCarthy
speakership debacle and we're going to be
experiencing this. I know David has also talked a
ton about this. We will be experiencing this for
the next two years and it will be a disaster
after disaster and debacle after debacle.